del balance es un poco tibio para los
sindicatos si bien ayer mucha gente
salió a marchar
740.000 según el gobierno más de dos
millones según los sindicatos fue menos
que la semana anterior y sobre todo
entre quienes marchaban jóvenes pero ya
no vimos por ejemplo a esas personas
trabajadores activos o personas mayores
que están quizás a punto de jubilarse
por lo tanto los sindicatos han
comenzado a abrirse a un diálogo con el
gobierno lo mencionábamos ayer el líder
del sindicato más conservador cfdt se ha
acercado comenzó a hacer propuestas a
pedir que se suspenda la reforma y
también la mediación de alguna político
alguien con el gobierno pero el gobierno
ayer Ya decía que no quería mediación ni
tampoco suspensión Pero bueno hoy la
primera ministra Elizabeth los ha
invitado a conversar la semana que viene
alguno de los días tres cuatro cinco de
abril se dice ha dicho que será mucho
los temas que se pueden hablar los gatos
y los hombres y el líder de la fdt dice
que obviamente va a mencionar la
necesidad de bajar la edad de jubilación
a los sesenta y de los sesenta y cuatro
años a los 62 como es actualmente y que
nadie le va a imponer a él lo que tiene
que decir pero algunos líderes del
oficialismo incluido el ministro de
relaciones con el parlamento han dicho
que ese tema El de los 64 años no va a
estar en la en la orden del día de esa
reunión en todo caso también lo
mencionábamos ayer la primera ministra
Elizabeth está decidida a entrar en una
comunicación con los políticos
parlamentarios alcaldes pero también con
los líderes sindicales para preparar
también los proyectos a futuro para que
haya concertación acuerdo y no ocurra
una crisis social como la que estamos
viviendo actualmente